foreign
one of the things we say around Ramsey
all the time is personal finance is 80
Behavior it's only 20 head knowledge and
getting the guy in the mirror to behave
is is the battle and and you've you've
got a lot to say uh on that subject so
talk about what you've discovered around
the correlation between just a mental uh
stability and mental maturity mental
health maturity and and that how that
correlates to wealth
well people it's easy to presume that
the reason people are poor is because
they don't have enough money
but that's an oversimplification very
few complex things are attributable to a
single cause
um I had lots of clients who were much
better off when they had no money at all
those are often people who had addiction
problems because as soon as they had any
money at all they're just in the bar and
into the cocaine until they were face
down in a ditch and
so there's there's all sorts of causes
of poverty and certainly one form of
poverty and one cause of poverty is
absence of a plan
I mean you need to develop a vision for
your life and that makes delaying
gratification for example and not
engaging in impulsive momentary pleasure
worthwhile because you're building
towards something that you actually want
to attain and we're very very bad at in
our society like appallingly and
miraculously bad at helping people
develop a vision we don't do it with
students in school for example not at
all and it's it's really like I said
it's a miracle of stupidity
so
it is it truly is it's the it's the
number one thing we should be teaching
people and we don't do it at all
I want to be and
what do you want your life to look like
in five years what are you building
towards why are you
gratification assuming you are why are
you saving for example or working like
what what's your vision what makes it
worthwhile and how do you even come up
with a notion like that
and the strange thing the strange thing
is when you have a vision that's very
very clear and high definition uh
burnout just kind of goes away you get
tired like your schedule has been
horrendous but you're not burnt out
you're probably tired but you're not
burnt out
yeah well I mean look
all the positive emotion we feel that uh
except for the type that is just a
consequence of basic satisfaction you
know the sort of satisfaction you might
have after a big meal all the enthusiasm
and excitement and hope and curiosity
essential meaning in life all of that
all of that is experienced in
relationship to a goal when you see
yourself moving towards a goal then
you're inspired you have you have hope
you have enthusiasm you have energy
um you can communicate effectively and
enthusiastically no goal you have none
of that no vision no goal
so
you're not going to get tired and and
feel what would you say hard done by if
your sacrifices and the difficult things
that you're endeavoring to do are
clearly worthwhile by your own
definition
one of the things I do I have an
exercise online called it's at
self-authoring.com called future
authoring and we built this to help
people develop a vision and one of the
things we ask people to do is just to
sit for 15 minutes write for 15 minutes
badly
here's the game imagine you were taking
care of yourself like someone you cared
for so imagine someone you care for and
pretend that's you maybe it's a son or a
daughter or a friend
now imagine five years down the road you
can have what you want need you can be
who you are but you have to figure out
what it is what is it what do you want
what do you need
and and don't worry about getting it
right just get it down for 15 minutes
that's a good start the whole exercise
you can do in about 90 minutes but we
had
students do that say before they went to
University
and just doing it for 90 minutes
developing that Vision drop their
dropout rate 90 or 50 percent 50 percent
and increase the grade point average 35
percent
and that just shows you how badly it had
been done before because
students went to University with no
vision they have no idea what they were
doing there and so of course they didn't
half of them didn't succeed because they
had no idea why they were doing anything
well that's not helpful or wise and the
reason that's the case by the way is
because our school system was set up to
produce
mindless obedient workers by essentially
by fascists at the end of the 1800s
that's well documented historically it
was based on the Prussian military model
and they wanted to produce obedient
soldiers and we haven't updated our
notion of what schools are for for 140
years yeah Ken Coleman says we've not
made Pathfinders we've made test takers
we're not even very good at that
well Dr Peterson I'm curious Pathfinders
we have so many similar principles we
want to help people avoid the pitfalls
of education and debt and we're both
kind of Truth tellers in a world gone
mad and that can be counter-cultural
controversial offensive at times what is
the secret sauce to really connecting
with those people and getting to change
a paradigm and actually getting out of
debt or doing that hard thing
well I think a huge part of that is to
get them to start conceptualizing
themselves as people who could be
pursuing
um a goal that they found compelling
rather than people who are driven by
circumstances I think it's 35 40 percent
of Young Americans now feel they have no
agency in their life
and you say well how do you you have to
entice people into I suppose the
hypothesis of a vision and you do that
with while this
this meditative exercise for example
that I describe just imagine for a
moment that you could have what you
needed and wanted
man and I mean literally imagine that
Daydream like you did when you were a
kid
now you know you want to bind that with
a little bit of intelligent rationality
you you know you you don't want to be
if you're starting it from scratch maybe
you don't want to be thinking that in
five years you're gonna inhabit a 350
room Mansion you know in in Malibu
although stranger things have happened
to people you know you wanna foreign
you want to develop your vision within
the realm of possibility but that
doesn't but and you and you should be
honest enough with yourself so it's
actually something compelling to you you
know the other thing we ask people to do
and I'm talking about this because it's
very practical you might say well I
don't know what I want it's like okay
well what other people have that it
seems to work for them you probably want
a relationship what's your vision for
that you probably want to have something
approximating a family of some sort
what's your vision for that even if it's
your parents not children necessary not
even a wife necessarily some family
connections some friendship some job or
career some educational goals some
strategy for dealing with Temptations
that's five things some conception of
how you would use your time
intelligently outside of work
um some conception of how you might what
would you say uphold your civic
responsibility yeah there's there's
sources of meaning that people that
people generally have